dying light 2 tech land sequel to the
world renowned dying light 1 has just
been released and since i had just
recently beaten the game i want to put
together an explanation video for you
all as not only is dying light 2's story
a bit long and confusing you could have
missed a few important moments while you
were trying to drop kick people off
skyscrapers as always spoiler warning
ahead as we'll be covering the main
story of the game so if you haven't
beaten dying light 2 i strongly
recommend you do that then come back of
course there's always going to be
timestamps in the description and on the
timeline if you need to go to a specific
spot before we continue though i wanted
to take a quick ad break to talk about
our sponsor of today's video atlasvpn if
you haven't heard of them before they're
a premium vpn service that are currently
running a special promotion here on the
channel where you can get 82 percent off
a three-year plan which is about 1.99 a
month a vpn for those who don't know is
a virtual private network that puts all
your internet traffic through an
encrypted channel which means it can
protect your information like search
history and ip address from being put in
the wrong hands atlas vpn also comes
with a built-in data breach monitor
that'll keep you updated if an account
of yours has been breached and
furthermore has a tracker blocker
feature which blocks you from entering
potentially dangerous websites it's no
secret that its most popular use has
been for streaming services you can use
atlas vpn to connect to a server from
any country which enables certain shows
that you may not be able to watch in
your country however it also has some
major uses for gaming by changing
servers your ping could be lower so you
can experience a more stable connection
and plus there's also the added benefit
of not getting booted offline assuming
someone tries to hit you off if this
interests you in any way you can click
the link in the description down below
to get a special deal that gives you 82
off a three year plan as always thank
you to atlas vpn for sponsoring today's
video now let's get back to the content
so before dying light 2 even starts we
get a lengthy cutscene detailing some
past events leading up to the present
day after haran had been quote wiped off
the map scientists and researchers
eventually found a vaccine however the
gre continued to research the virus for
military purposes eventually a new
strain of the virus was made and was
more catastrophic as this too escaped
and since it didn't have the walls of
haran holding it back it could go
wherever it wanted within two years by
2023 98 of the population was gone and
while many settlements and villages
would survive the last major place on
earth would be villadore the setting for
dying light too this is something we'll
see later in the game and it's a double
meaning of the words that teclan chooses
to use to provide some context from the
previous game as we know from dying
light 1 crane was successful in stopping
the gre from carpet bombing haran but
ultimately had to make a choice between
nuking the city or defeating the mother
but then becoming a volatile apparently
the developers of the game have stated
that both dying light 1 and dying light
2 are about the player's interpretation
of the story meaning if you want to
believe corinne is a volatile then go
for it or if you want to believe that he
blew up the nuke then you can do that
too according to the official dying
light twitter account it says dying
light 2 is set around 15 years in the
future in a different part of the world
so the events of the following affected
only indirectly to my knowledge there
was no confirmation in this game of what
actually happened to haran and that word
wiped out could mean two different
things as the context of wiped out could
mean that the infection destroyed the
city or was wiped out as in a nuke wiped
it completely from the map going back to
the story the virus was spreading too
quickly in the city so the gre used this
special gas that they claimed was a
medication but actually ended up killing
a bunch of people and making the ground
impossible to walk on this is why
there's those large pockets of yellow
stains on the ground in villadore as its
leftover residue from the chemicals this
oddly enough relates to a comic book
released a few months before the game
called banshee where we see the entire
city has been gassed by a supposed
anti-viral medication except it actually
created more infected there's also an
extremely important story detail in here
as our main protagonist hands off her
necklace to a friend of hers before she
dies as it's shown that this necklace
has the data needed to complete the
vaccine this is all well and good but
the main character ends up turning into
the banshee that boss we fight in the
first hour of the game and that necklace
never gets brought up again so
maybe a dlc i'm not sure moving on to
the present we start off dying light 2
in the year 2036 15 years after the fall
of humanity with a cut scene of our new
protagonist aiden running from a horde
of infected shortly after we meet a
friend of his who is revealed to be
spike the same one from haran these two
are considered pilgrims who are
essentially nomadic survivors that
travel from place to place they aren't
the most liked people in the world but
they're definitely not hated either due
to their isolated nature many people
based their opinions on the group on the
few that they've met as we see with
spike and aiden despite them being quite
friendly with another they rarely ever
get chances to talk or travel together
it's during this talk where aiden
reveals to us his true end goal which is
to find his sister according to aiden
when they were kids both him and his
sister were subjected to constant
testing by some scientists throughout
the game though we do uncover the main
parts of the story from both flashbacks
and present-day information according to
veronica who was not present for the
testing but was there to collect data
from those tests explains the gre was
desperate for finding a cure so they
ended up using kids as test subjects
apparently children showed natural
immunity to the virus as it was proven
that there was some correlation between
age brain development and the virus
severity they then subjected these kids
to all sorts of tests and hoping of
finding a cure the person overseeing
most of these tests was a man named dr
waltz sadly while they were close to a
vaccine the virus had reached the
laboratory and thus halted lots of
progress during this time mia got
infected because despite her being
within the age range to be immune to the
virus she had a weaker immune system
than most of the other kids which is how
it was able to enter her body the
problem is that these flashbacks tell a
different story aiden had flashbacks
constantly throughout the game and they
paint aiden as mia's brother who will do
anything to save her his flashbacks also
paint dr walt as a horrible doctor that
treated the kids poorly for example
watch these flashbacks
the first one was aiden's memory of the
moments but when confronting waltz the
memory is different not only is one
showing more of the memory than the
other but mia also screams in the first
one and when in fact she didn't scream
at all in the other memory this decision
from techland to make the memories this
way makes this harder to talk about as
it's unclear what is right and what is
wrong the only person that can provide
us some additional information is lawan
who we meet later in the game as she was
a part of the same program as aiden and
mia and judging from her reactions it's
clear she didn't like it either but once
again it's up in the air as it's
possible that only aiden and mia were
treated fine but everyone else wasn't
and there's also a poem from one of the
kids at the laboratory saying how great
it was and how wonderful dr waltz is to
everyone this could be backed up by what
walt says at the end of the game because
according to him mia is his daughter
this is such a huge detail that barely
gets any mention after this which once
again makes this harder to talk about if
both aiden and waltz are telling the
truth being that aiden and mia are
siblings and that waltz's daughter is
mia that makes aiden his son but this
revelation never gets brought up again
waltz never calls aidan his son and ada
never questions him on this discovery
this leads into a long string of
theories it's possible that each of them
meant these words without the
blood-related meaning waltz could have
used the word daughter in the sense of
she's like a daughter to me and aidan
may have been doing the same but with
the word sister like mia is like a
sister to aiden given that aiden only
remembers a fragment of his childhood
and it's also quite possible that waltz
could just be saying all this to trick
aiden we don't actually know what's
going on here however the strongest
theory is that waltz and mia are father
and daughter and that aiden was just a
friend of hers as walt mentions that
aiden made a promise with him that no
matter what happens they stick together
this is further reinforced by the fact
that if aiden was related to waltz he
would have referred to him as son
regardless this still doesn't explain
the facility and whether or not this is
actually a good place or not because the
one may say it's terrible but everyone
else seemed to enjoy it this seems to be
left up in the air on purpose so do let
me know what you think as for my
concluding thoughts i think aiden is
misremembering his childhood which made
him think that mia is his sister and
that while a laboratory may have been a
terrible place i think dr waltz was
actually nice to the kids fast
forwarding once again to the present
aiden is still dead set on finding mia
to clarify everything we discussed so
far aiden doesn't know yet so for all he
knows his sister is in the city and dr
waltz who tortured him is also in the
city he sneaks into vildor with the help
of an informant however during the trek
underneath the city aidan is spotted and
bitten by a volatile he is then saved
but is now considered infected
afterwards the informant is captured by
waltz and his army called the renegades
they captured him so they can get this
item called a gre access key which was
used by the gre to open up all sorts of
equipment and facilities used by them
aiden is then instructed to take the key
and head to the fisheye in vildor to
meet with lawan after being chased out
of the vent by waltz he manages to make
it topside where he arrives at the
bazaar stumbling from both being out of
breath and almost close to turning
thanks to the bite from earlier aden
gets a warm welcome for the people of
the bizarre as they immediately try to
hang him in the nick of time though he's
saved by hakan and is temporarily
treated it's clear that from this
cutscene that the haron virus is similar
to this strain in some ways however it
does differ when it comes to infection
rate after a human becomes infected
they'll reach the first stage of the
infection once they reach stage 4 the
infection can no longer be stopped the
only way to lessen the effects of the
viruses either through uv light or other
medication like anticin crane
experienced similar seizures in dying
light 1 but was able to patrol during
the night without the risk of turning as
long as he was able to take a consistent
amount of antizin then he wouldn't turn
but undyingly 2 this doesn't seem to be
enough uv light is now more important
than ever as against the heron virus uv
light just seem to only affect the
volatiles whereas in dying light 2 it
not only affects the volatiles and other
affected types but it can also halt the
strain temporarily the key detail is
halting the virus it can't go away but
as long as someone stays in sunlight or
a black light then it won't progress
this is why there's that immunity timer
when entering dark areas as the light
from either the sun or a black light
isn't touching our skin so we're
becoming a zombie this is also why
everyone carries these light up
wristbands is according to hakkon a few
minutes later everyone in the city is
infected one way or another and these
wristbands are used to tell the person
wearing it when they're close to turning
that's also another reason the people of
the bazaar tried to hang us as we didn't
have one of these wristbands and not
only provides information to you but to
others as well if someone notices that
your watch is blinking red then they can
judge whether or not to be near you
since you might turn into an infected
sun so the people take this wristband
requirement very seriously because of
the severity hakkon takes us to a place
that may have some extra wristbands
lying around aidan gets a wristband and
narrowly escapes his own death by a few
seconds as he rushes out to safety heck
out and aiden discuss the next step and
hack on offers to help him if aiden gets
him out of the city the two agree and
then discuss our next step which is to
get to the city center as that's where
the fisheye and lawan are except nothing
is ever simple because the leader of the
other faction in the city the
peacekeepers was murdered and certain
sections of the city are under lockdown
until the killer is found this forces
aiden and hackon to take an underground
passage past the guards and into the
city center things don't go to plan as
we get another warm welcome from the
peacekeepers although to be fair maitor
immediately listened to our side of the
story instead of trying to hang us so
i'd say we're off to a great start while
aiden is released from their custody
another deal was made between the two
ator will grant aiden access to the city
center if he can help find who killed
commander lucas according to etor there
are three things that could identify the
killer one being the brass knuckles he
carried around as someone took them off
his corpse the second is his tattoo
insignia which someone cut off him and
the third being a large wound with these
lines made by the knuckles themselves
this sequence of quest is also the first
of many choices we can make in the main
story this part is centered around both
factions as adore believes that the
people at the bazaar killed commander
lucas this then forces you to take some
odd jobs for the bizarre to gain their
trust sadly after a few hours of
missions we aren't anywhere closer to
finding the culprits and the only thing
we can gather is that the peacekeepers
don't know who killed lucas and neither
do the people at the bazaar however we
come to report the news to sophie but
the camp she was at was attacked
possibly by peacekeepers we're about to
head inside to check out the damage
until hakkon calls this telling us to
not get involved in these civil
conflicts and that we should just tell
adr what we know and we could leave this
is the first major decision of the game
with many more to come and i'll do my
best to explain them all but do keep in
mind many of them aren't as expansive as
you think if you choose to tell sophie
and head inside upon entering the
building there are survivor and pk
bodies everywhere we hear adar on the
radio and respond back to him letting
him know his men are dead but it was a
trap as barney a character we've been
seeing quite frequently during these
missions appears and says that we're a
pk spy this goes into a lengthy boss
fight where we have to defeat some of
his men as well as herman sophie's
bodyguard we then find the two one are
able to talk but sophie and barney want
nothing to do with us this also leads
into a few other choices should we say
the words we can help each other it sort
of reverts your previous decision and
you can help the survivors take back the
water tower from this duo named jack and
joe however the other option cuts ties
with them and you can continue helping
aider with the investigation this choice
is very similar to the first choice when
you choose not to intervene and just go
to the metro but just one gets you to
ater quicker than the other when we go
back to ader he believes that we can
retake the water tower then they'll have
to give up the killer as the pks can
starve them of water however we can
still choose to give the water tower to
the survivors as this leads into the
faction alignment system your choice
here ultimately doesn't matter as soon
after this decision hakon will call you
and tell you to meet at the motel so we
can look around for evidence as now both
barney and sophie are gone we can then
enter the room that they blocked us from
entering and while we do find some
typical things around the room we can
also find that tattoo insignia the
commander lucas wore while it doesn't
make any sense while it's just sitting
in a back room this is enough evidence
to put barney on trial and question him
the pks will arrive and subdue barney
and ader congratulates us and allows us
passage into the city center now that
we've caught the killer but and is this
starting to get repetitive because
nothing goes right again hakkon and
aiden gets separated and after barely
making it out alive we see smoke arise
from a pk windmill which explains why
the electricity was out in the metro
tunnel if you however chose to side with
the survivors during these missions then
this tunnel mission we just discussed
and the previous investigation with
barney never actually happen and you end
up joining them on the assault of the
windmill and since you helped them
sophie will take you to the city center
instead both end up with the same
problem though because of the ongoing
war with these two factions part of the
tunnel we're supposed to ender got blown
up and there's no way to get into the
city center just yet hakkon also calls
us shortly after to meet at his hideout
and upon entering hakkon gets shot with
an arrow while we tend to his wound we
discover that he was the one who killed
commander lucas because the gash is on
his chest this leaves us with two more
choices of leaving him to die or
rescuing him rescuing him goes into a
short side quest which sees you hunting
the sniper down but ultimately either
choice will continue into the next quest
aiden discovers that waltz the man he's
been trying to hunt is at an abandoned
car factory nearby so it and goes and
tries to reroute the power if you sided
with the pks then ader and the group
will join you but if you sided with the
survivors ader will join but doesn't
know that you're here and is quite
unpleased to see you you either then
have a nice chat or get into an argument
depending on the faction you chose but
after rerouting the power ader and the
group will capture waltz however waltz
has some superhuman abilities and is
somehow able to overpower the entire
group with ease we pass out and wake up
later with renegade soldiers near us but
while trying to fight them aiden has
some sort of seizure and sort of becomes
an infected who makes quick work of all
the guards this happens quite frequently
but to explain a bit more it seems to be
a combination of the infection and also
the tests run by dr waltz as according
to him out of all the children adam
performed the best and bonded with the
substances the most we escape the tunnel
and are able to get a really good look
at the sheer amount of chemicals that
were dropped here as this entire area is
inhabitable we once again find wall to
use our gre access key waltz also
discovers that we are one of the kids at
the laboratory but it gets even more
interesting as moments before he chokes
us out in and asks what he did with mia
which stops him completely after what
felt like hours of running we finally
outrun him and discover that the sniper
who helped us liz lawan the girl we've
been trying to meet we travel with lawan
to her hideout and for the first time in
15 years the power to the whole city is
back on sadly it doesn't last long and
the power turns off again but it does
prove that the power can come back the
one then accompanies us to the fisheye
and upon entering mimi with frank and
are also ambushed by renegades who
attack the area after defeating them we
meet with jack matt the major of the
peacekeepers we ask him where a gre
database is as this database could be
our only chance of discovering where mia
is this goes into a long string of
missions that aren't necessary for the
sake of this video until we make it to
the observatory the reason being is that
this observatory while apparently
destroyed may still have some info on
mia and their experiments sadly it is
extremely destroyed and surrounded by
chemicals so there's no way to get
inside aiden then has another seizure
but wakes up in an entirely different
place with bodies surrounding him we
reconvene with major matt who has a plan
and a deal for aiden matt wants to turn
the power on from the vnc tower which
should be able to keep electricity on
for the whole city but in return he'll
find out if there are any gre scientists
still left after the infection this
group of quests is the next instance of
choice in the main story to assault the
tower we need lots of uv lamps but the
only one who can source them is juan who
is not doing his job juan will give you
the choice of sticking with him or
believing in major matt this choice will
lead to our next choice which is who to
give the power to major matt juan or
frank matt will use the radio to
broadcast propaganda to the city juan
shroud is the same as matt's but with
juan being able to plug a back door in
so to speak so we can spy on matt's
transmissions and frank's option is to
revive radio new hope it may seem odd
why we would help this drunken fool but
from talking with frank and learning
more about the vnc tower we discovered
that frank was the leader of a group
called the nightrunners people brave
enough to search for supplies at night
and help those who couldn't get home in
time his team was going to do exactly
what we did and assault the vnc tower to
make radio new hope except the plan
frank had needed everyone on board
however one of its members didn't agree
to the plan which then led to others
disagreeing causing the plan to be
ruined those who left also left the
peacekeepers and those who stayed
continued with the plan but were all
slaughtered and frank was the only
survivor we can also see how dangerous
this mission really was as our group of
peacekeepers that we went with was
completely wiped out upon entering the
30th floor that's why i chose to go with
frank's option in my game however there
is a problem by siding with frank we
break the deal with matt and now refuses
to find a gre scientist for us
regardless of your choice though you'll
still end up finding the scientist as
the person who actually finds her is
hakhan before we get into that during
these missions there was a quick side
quest with luan where you can end up
discovering that she and hakon used to
be together she then explains why and
it's clear that hakan is not a nice
person he lied to you about who killed
commander lucas he works for waltz and
he also left and broke ties with lawan
that's why this next part is quite a
tough decision hekon tells us that he
was the one who was against the raid of
the vnc tower meaning he was technically
responsible for all those night runners
dying however after this he wanted to
track down waltz but ended up getting
caught by him fearing for his friend's
life he cut ties with everyone like
frank lawan and many others as their
lives would be in danger so he didn't
leave lawan for no reason he wanted to
protect her that's why he works with us
to find mia because of our promise
earlier if he helps us we have to get
him out of the city which makes sense as
he wants to be as far away from waltz as
possible so he can get on with his life
your previous decision with hakkon will
determine the outcome of this fight if
you saved his life then you can tell
hakkon that you don't want to fight
anymore and he agrees and the two of you
stop if you left him for dead then this
option doesn't appear and you have to
kill him lawan arrives shortly after and
will either mention how you got to him
first or thanks you for softening him up
for her this is probably the most
important decision in the whole game and
one we'll explain later but just know
that hakkon can either live or die here
depending on your choice now that this
detour has been finished we can finally
meet with the gre doctor dr ryan tells
us that after the fall of humanity
employees of the gre were rounded up and
executed and the only reason that she is
alive is because no one knows she's a
doctor after making it through the whole
facility we finally make it to the gre
database and can finally find out what
happened to mia except there's nothing
again the only relevant information we
find is that the tests aiden and the
kids were subjected to were run at a
facility called x13 and there was also a
map from a lab called x10 that has
several areas marked in vildor which
they discover is plans for a missile
strike after finding out this info aiden
and veronica will leave the lab until
renegades and waltz ambush them the two
escape but aiden has another seizure but
this time can't control it and kills
veronica with his bare hands you can
also see that her right arm and right
leg are completely missing from her body
after passing out lawan rescues him and
the two discuss how to take down both
the colonel and waltz i haven't
mentioned the colonel yet that much but
he is considered the butcher by many in
the game because he gave the order to
douse the city with chemicals this then
leads to the epilogue and starts the
point of no return to get to the
stronghold where the carnal resides we
have to sneak inside one of the
transport vans when we meet with the
colonel something is wrong he claims
that he and waltz aren't on speaking
terms anymore on top of this he denies
having his men ambush frank which
happened a bit earlier and denies the
missile strikes it's discovered that
waltz had betrayed the colonel and took
some of his men with him which explains
why the renegades here look different
than the ones we have faced thus far we
also learned that major matt ordered the
hit on frank which explains why he was
so adamant about aiden finding the
renegade van instead of helping frank
this part will only show up depending on
your choice at the broadcast so you may
not have experienced this equally lawan
has a chance of arriving at the
stronghold once again based on the
choice of the broadcast if you side with
the colonel then he'll take you to x13
so you can stop waltz except the driver
is killed on the way there and you're
forced to fight major matt and his
peacekeepers if you didn't side with the
colonel you defeat his henchmen and
lower the water from the dam which shows
an entirely new district that hasn't
been seen before to which you in major
math mount an attack on the building
that the colonel fled to you meet with
the colonel who holds you at gunpoint
but then tells you where to find x-13
before killing himself after this the
same thing happens where you take a
driver to the laboratory but it's
ambushed by not peacekeepers this time
but walt's renegades thankfully though
the nightrunners have arrived and
offered to help since you saved frank
from dying and also secreted the
broadcast tower for them no matter what
choice you pick after this you and lawan
make it to x13 in hopes of finding waltz
lawan is injured during this and needs
to stay back and of course depending on
your choice from earlier hakkon will
either show up or not because you let
him live he vows to take her to safety
while you deal with waltz except lawan
is lying while you defeat walt she goes
to where the missiles are being launched
and tries to stop them hakkon didn't
realize until way later but ends up
going after her and trying to save her
back to aiden we run down a hallway and
for the first time all game we finally
see mia she's hooked up to some
ventilator on a hospital bed which he is
indeed alive we then finally come face
to face with waltz this leads into that
part about waltz's daughter being mia
and all that stuff we discussed earlier
in the video so i'll skip it for the
sake of repeating myself a long boss
fight occurs and we can now finally talk
about the final ending of the game after
defeating waltz mia walks over and tries
to stop them both from fighting the two
fight over the gre access key which then
gets destroyed in the chemical waste and
then mia collapses right after the two
work together to get her back on the bed
so she can be hooked up to the
ventilator it seems that after all this
time waltz was trying to still find a
cure for mia even though it seems like
she doesn't want one anymore as she is
sick and tired of just being barely
alive thanks to this ventilator and not
being able to just die on her own terms
the reason these missiles launched in
the first place was due to a failsafe
that occurred at the facility because
waltz needed power to keep the
ventilator and his lab going because if
the power was off then the ventilator
wouldn't work and mia could die after
this we get our two choices the missiles
from the launch light are launching soon
and will destroy the city if they do we
can shut off the missiles or the power
the only way we can do this is to blow
them up before the launch except it
needs to be done manually so either we
have the missiles explode possibly
killing lawn while aiden takes mia
outside the lab or we leave mia in the
facility and try to save lawan if you
chose to save mia you'll take her out of
the lab at the nick of time and are able
to rescue her from the blast sadly
though that does mean lawn dies however
if you chose not to kill hakkon earlier
he will instead rescue lawn and everyone
survives the blast if we go with the
other option aiden instead tries to
rescue lawan he makes it to her who is
furious that he left waltz and mia to
save her adrien also freaks out and has
another seizure which caused him to lash
out and take her outside to safety but
it's too late as while he saved luan the
missiles launched destroying the city
from here we get a few different
cutscenes and answers to our choices
whoever controlled the most territories
becomes the leader of the city whether
that's the peacekeepers or the survivors
however i had the same amount of
territories for both of them so it's
possible that there are other
circumstances to prevent this from
occurring which is either the broadcast
decision frank being for the survivors
and matin juan being for the
peacekeepers or maybe it has to do with
the individual territories on the map
not just that faction alignment bar the
third cutscene is if the colonel is
alive which sees him take over the city
however if you did the lawan ending and
the city gets destroyed then a fourth
choice will trump all of our decisions
and shows the city in ruins after this
we will get a cutscene from spike who
drops off a package and asks if another
pilgrim was here in reference to aiden
we then come to the final cut scene
which has two different sections that
change depending on our choices
throughout the game the first part of
the ending is based on our last choice
if we pick the ending where we save mia
we find out that she died hours later
after we rescued her due to her weak
immune system if we save lawan then it
talks about aenein finding someone else
he cares for and tried to save her at
all costs the second part of this ending
changes depending on a variety of
choices that are extremely complicated
to explain and some of these choices may
not even have any weight in these
endings so i'd rather not get the info
wrong ultimately though the cutscene
here either has aiden walking off alone
walking with hakkon or walking with
lawan the reason he left was because the
drugs that were in his system from all
the tests he had on him and the
infection itself were turning him into a
monster as we saw with veronica so for
his and everyone else's safety he just
decided to leave the city this is the
final cutscene of dying light 2 and thus
means the end of the game the question
now becomes what's canon and what
happens next as stated before teclan
really wants the player to make their
own story for dying light 2 so there is
probably no canon ending here as for
what's next who really knows a dlc might
see aiden traveling to another village
but that's all i can think about maybe
there's some tie into that banshee comic
we talked about earlier but like i said
it's unconfirmed right now there's
definitely going to be dlc according to
the road map hosted by techland but
whether or not it'll be something like
the following from the first game
remains to be seen with that however
we've come to the end of the video as
always if you're confused about
something let me know in the comments
down below and i'll do my best to
explain it and of course let me know in
the comments what you thought about
dying light 2's story and what choices
you got in the comments as well be on
the lookout in the coming weeks and the
foreseeable future as not only will i
most likely have a video reviewing the
game's story as today is just a
retelling of its events i also plan to
make an entirely different story
explained video on a game releasing
quite soon horizon forbidden west thank
you all for watching today and if you
enjoyed make sure to like and subscribe
if you're new and as always thank you to
my returning viewers for coming back
take care everyone
and goodbye
[Music]
you